on September 1st 1953 William Scoville
used a hand crank and a cheap drill saw
to bore into a young man's skull cutting
away vital pieces of his brain and
sucking them out through a metal tube
but this wasn't a scene from a horror
film or a gruesome police report dr.
Scoville was one of the most renowned
neurosurgeons of his time and the young
man was Henry mOLAISON the famous
patient known as HM whose case provided
amazing insights into how our brains
work as a boy Henry had cracked his
skull in an accident and soon began
having seizures blacking out and losing
control of bodily functions after
enduring years of frequent episodes and
even dropping out of high school
the desperate young man had turned to
dr. Scoville a daredevil known for risky
surgeries partial lobotomies had been
used for decades to treat mental
patients based on the notion that mental
functions were strictly localized to
corresponding brain areas having
successfully used them to reduce
seizures in psychotics Scoville decided
to remove HMS hippocampus a part of the
limbic system that was associated with
emotion but whose function was unknown
at first glance the operation had
succeeded hm seizures virtually
disappeared with no change in
personality and his IQ even improved but
there was one problem his memory was
shot besides losing most of his memories
from the previous decade HM was unable
to form new ones
forgetting what day it was repeating
comments and even eating multiple meals
in a row when Scoville informed another
expert Wilder Penfield of the results he
sent a PhD student named Brenda Milner
to study HM at his parents home where he
now spent his days doing odd tours and
watching classic movies for the first
time over and over what she discovered
through a series of tests and interviews
didn't just contribute greatly to the
study of memory it redefined what memory
even meant one of Milner's findings shed
light on the obvious fact that although
HM couldn't form
new memories he still retained
information long enough from moment to
moment to finish a sentence or find the
bathroom when Milner gave him a random
number he managed to remember it for 15
minutes by repeating it to himself
constantly but only 5 minutes later he
forgot the test had even taken place
neuro scientists had thought of memory
as monolithic all of it essentially the
same and stored throughout the brain
Milner's results were not only the first
clue for the now-familiar distinction
between short-term and long-term memory
but showed that each uses different
brain regions we now know that memory
formation involves several steps after
immediate sensory data is temporarily
transcribed by neurons in the cortex it
travels to the hippocampus where special
proteins work to strengthen the cortical
synaptic connections if the experience
was strong enough or we recall it
periodically in the first few days the
hippocampus then transfers the memory
back to the cortex for permanent storage
HMS mind could form the initial
impressions but without a hippocampus to
perform this memory consolidation they
eroded like messages scrawled in sand
but this was not the only memory
distinction Milner found in a now famous
experiment she asked HM to trace a third
star in the narrow space between the
outlines of two concentric ones while he
could only see his paper and pencil
through a mirror like anyone else
performing such an awkward task for the
first time he did horribly but
surprisingly he improved over repeated
trials even though he had no memory of
previous attempts his unconscious motor
centres remembered what the conscious
mind had forgotten what Milner had
discovered was that the declarative
memory of names dates and facts is
different from the procedural memory of
riding a bicycle or signing your name
and we now know that procedural memory
relies more on the basal ganglia and
cerebellum structures that were intact
in HMS brain this distinction between
knowing that and knowing how has
underpinned all memory research
hm died at the age of 82 after a mostly
peaceful life in a nursing home over the
years he had been examined by more than
100 neuroscientists making his the most
studied mind in history upon his death
his brain was preserved and scanned
before being cut into over 2,000
individual slices and photographed to
form a digital map down to the level of
individual neurons all in a live
broadcast watched by 400,000 people
though HM spent most of his life
forgetting things he and his
contributions to our understanding of
memory will be remembered for
generations to come